[Music]
by the way as of today the the are
finally our our kalila video about our
uh so you know our conspiracy theory
about her being responsible for the
Reddit drama has gone up and there's a
lot of people that are agreeing with it
so that's had in the universe now but I
figured what we would do merch is we
would watch and see how Bobby is holding
up after he you know holding up dating
now that he's broken up okay and I think
the best way to do that and the
healthiest way to do it is for him to
have to explain it to his ex-girlfriend
who he still lives with
so I want to know an update on your uh
dating life
none of your business [ __ ] you're not
dating me anymore this is the problem
this is every time they go mate well we
could stay good friends no that doesn't
work okay
you you cannot I don't want to be
friends imagine explaining your current
sex life to a girl you just broke up to
every single day on a show
what do you mean
well you know what today I can tell you
how his dating life is going because
he's a 40 year old man and he's not in
with 50. he's not an escape actually
oh my God then this joke doesn't work
anymore because I was gonna say [ __ ]
he's a 40 year old man with painted
nails and he's not an Escape the Fate
but I need to [ __ ]
further yeah yeah well not only that can
I just tell you guys what that what
dating looks like for about all right
well that's not called can somebody let
me tell you what dating looks like for
Bobby well the only perception you would
have is dating looks like for Bobby he
lets people manipulate him and walk on
him isn't that right Bobby
what the [ __ ] man no names no names no
names okay all right no names like by
the way she says no but hey there's that
fake that's a tattoo that she said she
got because she cut herself on her wrist
but then you find out if she had her
ex-boyfriend's name tattooed on there I
have never seen someone go at such
lightning speed on three simultaneous
dating apps didn't you kiss his producer
like a week after
I mean yeah we can't all just fly to
Hawaii to [ __ ] some dude I've never seen
somebody go on dating apps and let me
tell you something I [ __ ] jerked off
a lot of dogs wait what
yeah and I mean he's swiping life well
he's swiping life he kind of is swiping
live He's swiping he's swiping left on
the hottest yeah just because Bobby uses
Tinder to find chicks and you use the
PetSmart app doesn't necessarily mean
that you go to chewy.com yeah [ __ ] it
seriously or [ __ ] or you're all [ __ ]
out of me because like it's getting
extra windy out here all right we're
back we are back and I apologize just in
case you missed it what I said was she's
upset because Bobby Lee uses Tinder to
find dates and she uses PetSmart and
then my next joke was going to be or
23andMe
now now we're good picks like I look at
it I'm like I cannot believe okay nice
you're impossible to impress he has
standards
no he doesn't he dated kalila for like
five million years yeah you can't be
that [ __ ] hard to impress he has
standards are you [ __ ] kidding me I
just look at the photo of the person you
could have been on a Netflix movie with
Jamie Foxx
I look at background what where are they
standing what is that is is that a is
that a chicken finger chicken finger on
her bed he said chicken fingers is that
a Ching finger on her back I'm seeing a
lot of [ __ ] fingers in this video
got nervous there for a second yeah yeah
that's whatever [ __ ] finger is what
kalila calls it when she hooks up with
her brother I meant to say oh okay
that's racist
she fingers on anybody's bed right
you're protecting yes dude no I look at
like if they're doing something like
they could be beautiful but if they're
doing something that I don't but she's
dying
tell the kid
tell the kids or the ice cream thing
isn't true either yeah it's not true
none of it's true none of it's true tell
the kid you want to be doing yeah like
skydiving or like playing golf or like
going to a club I just immediately I
don't want anything to do with it so you
don't want anybody that like has a life
I don't understand
right so I look at close that all right
sometimes various Nails paintings I'll
see the first photo I'm not sure it's a
joke I was making is that he's a 50 year
old man with painted nails and he's not
an Escape the Fate yeah and the second
photo make a decision they're mostly
laps for 13. I don't want to be who want
to be a Korean idiot no no no no no no
no no no no no no
for 13 hours of that entire flight from
LA to Manila it was just him I think
it's pronounced vanilla yeah chocolate's
better
hinge him remember that famous fight the
Thrilla in vanilla I could not believe
my eyes well you took a 13-hour flight
to an envelope you did get out of the
store you [ __ ] idiot what can I say
this you don't have a Staples near you
[Music]
no Bumble on Office Depot why I'm on
Bumble three of them simultaneous so
he's on Raya bum before Tinder and hinge
all of them yeah Tinder is good yeah
Tinder is Tinder it's mythological it's
interesting it's if um if if Middle
Earth had like a dating app that's what
Tinder is because I've literally seen
goblins
Bobby's a [ __ ] mess kalila looks like
somebody
well who [ __ ] her brother but kalila
looks like somebody who doesn't want to
be with Bobby but is mad that Bobby is
trying to be with somebody else that's
what it is right
I'm gonna be rude
Patrol
you know hey
man and also notice something ever since
the breakup she just sandbags this bro
this guy I have oh yeah she is you know
at a club you know what I mean do you
not think that maybe she thinks the same
of you when she comes across exactly I
peer disgust
don't you think she thinks the theme of
you when she comes across their P kalila
I gotta tell you something and I know
you watch these because you [ __ ]
[ __ ] silent move your silent movie
Esther uh co-host does
um
please understand something
how dare you talk about anything after
you're [ __ ] two not one but two
brothers step in real
and jerked off [ __ ] dogs like I mean
after after that and oh by the way
multiple dogs being 51.50 for the hat
trick three times
yeah but maybe you're not the person to
be giving advice for anything unless the
advice is how do you properly jerk off a
dog
I mean exactly Lila I'm probably never
gonna jerk off a dog but if I wanted
advice on jerking off dogs you would be
the first person I go to yeah well hula
girl first because she looks like she
probably does but then kalila
and probably easier to get in contact
with that one on the count of the broken
brain
I look like [ __ ] you know I mean
yellow Gollum two trolls won't make a
right she's like ah yellow yeah they
make a laugh they make a laugh they make
it they make up shoes that's not as
funny as you think it is producer
control right now and all this stuff but
there is somebody that
a couple of people I've met
that I like that I'm kind of have you
heard of Eliza Schlesinger
what if he starts dating this oh my God
Delilah would just kill herself okay
like a famous hot white chick yes seeing
so
that being said Scarlett Johansson
walking around with Bobby Lee and a
little papoose on her [ __ ] chest
little baby baby little baby carrier
foreign
s truth
I have to carry him like this so I can
get the dishes done that's the only way
he's very fidgety he loves his meth I
like I like hang out with and then I
like their energy and um
maybe you know I have a curious question
uh do you ever when you're swiping in
the back your mind do you ever
put kalila in like like you're comparing
why do they why do they look and I'm
glad you guys do because you've made us
a lot of money on our clip Channel but
why do you guys
do this to yourself on purpose like it's
one thing and I think it sucks when like
some people's [ __ ] gets hacked or you
know leaked or DMS get leaked it's like
bro that's not that's not that guy's
fault you know like that's kind of
[ __ ] up that somebody did that but
like to purposely go on a show and with
your ex who is just just in my opinion a
mastermind to the biggest downfall
you've ever had Bobby and then sit here
and then let your producer sit there and
try to just poke you both and who's this
other guy on the right what is that guy
what's going on here I have no idea
ever yeah she's here's that's the [ __ ]
up part
shut up that's the truth we're just
talking I wish you would have told her
when you were dating [ __ ] truth we're
being truthful little coochie mama
now
anyway yeah it's obviously you know
there's a level right and it's not just
about looks it's about you know
it's about Dick you know what means her
interests you know we have the same
interests we have the same we like the
same kind of music and who cares good
call [ __ ]
there we go
you know some interesting movies in
television
and comedy she has to be a big fan of
Mad TV especially the earlier Seasons
yeah whatever
um and then number three not the ones
with Callan not the ones with Callan she
has to [ __ ] hate Brian Callan love
any sketch well I do the Asia asset they
can't play golf Frozen is that you
wait at all
I hate golf what if they hey what if
they're hardcore Gamers is it because of
your dad yeah he's defeating with the
golf club
okay so no golf bowling ladies hate
bowling so no bowling because of you
I've seen you bowl with her so many
times I know but okay that's actually
pretty funny I hate bowling because when
I've seen you bowl with her many times
she's about to go yeah I know that's why
I [ __ ] that's why I hate it it's
pretty funny every time every time we
did it I [ __ ] hated it
I love it
that's a good drop oh that is that's a
good drop everything every time I did it
I hated it of course you did I know but
I went and I love it I love eating a
chicken that you love the chicken wings
yeah like eating the chicken there what
is another thing no you already have
four I have another one what [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] Burning Man okay that's a big
one interest or any Festival you have to
go to understand it though
what Whitey I have a question when
you've been making out with these girls
like have you improved on your kissing
oh my God she is just trying to get in
his head and sabotage her man bro
I can Bobby now you're leading her
humility
it's worse this is wait this is a worse
outcome than at least if he was [ __ ]
her
I mean
Jesus she will stop at nothing until
this dude kills himself oh my God you're
gonna [ __ ] don't you're gonna get
better at kissing
what what an evil [ __ ] she's horrible
what an evil [ __ ] she's the worst not
Bobby Lee great guy girl girl great guy
Bruce picture great guy
he's not giving you tips over the years
there's two things that I want to say
let's do it number one
I think you're wrong about that I don't
think I think you're the one that
doesn't own a kiss
think yeah
this is like when Rocky cut the [ __ ]
Russian's eye bro yes yes this is [ __ ]
yeah get him get him
oh [ __ ]
uh here you go I got it but it's just
here we go here it is
get him Bobby
let's go what do you got right right
because it's a clip and I don't want to
get monetized when I put it on YouTube
okay
right
I eat good then
good badge
what a weird way of saying no one that's
good at like eating out a girl calls it
eating good vag that sounds good just
the way he made that sound gross hey are
you are you good at eating veg Virgie
huh tell us an intricate detail about
bad meetings oh God it's grossing
comfortable oh what do you do what do
you do with your tongue when you're
badge eating hey honey why don't you
whip out that badge so I can eat it yeah
pop out that badge
Daddy's hungry
[Laughter]
I know
and I like it she didn't like me doing
it on her
no
because you could taste the dog [ __ ] huh
yeah
she didn't like when I did it to her
because I'm not her brother
your [ __ ] because I'm not in any of her
family photos yeah she stopped [ __ ]
me when I got hip dysplasia
foreign
why do you keep giving me CBD treats
before bed
oh [ __ ]
I'll tell you what after the show I want
to go eat some veg oh bro I'm gonna see
so much badge tonight
can't wait I'm gonna get a bib for all
the badge I'm eating it's not Lobster
not the way not the way you eat it
why because I don't do the spit no what
what the Bobby
what does that mean you stick your head
in her [ __ ] I'm trying to understand
here
with her probably you should do it
look man you're never going to impress
the woman that's used to putting peanut
butter on her [ __ ] and letting a dog
[ __ ] eat her [ __ ] seriously and she
uses crap and she's a freaker she uses
crunchy
um
yeah that's how you could tell uh
I always like the crunchy I prefer the
crunchy
which is the way to do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not gonna
put your vagina in a kumura yeah she's
[ __ ] calling Walmart and being like
hey do you have any peanut butter
flavored Monistat I have a whole thing
going on
Jesus Christ [ __ ] so much yeast and
peanut butter in there she's making
cookies
[Laughter]
it's like I'm gonna use my mouth you're
good but you're very polite
okay here we go right very polite right
I don't listen I didn't do toxic
masculinity that's not even that dude I
learned through porn
right
what do you what porn are you watching
what hold on a second can I ask a
question here
kalila what porn are you watching
because she's probably into some
disgusting [ __ ] she's the reason incest
is the top horn search
it's just a good thing to do
this is a little confusing I don't want
to get too graphic but right yeah say
less graphic say less I lick the thumb
you lick it good yeah yeah right just
because that's my style lubricant no it
doesn't go anywhere you just
give her a thumbs up like look at my
shiny thumb
but it's even because it's funny because
when you watch kalila talk about Bobby
all she brings up is like how terrible
he was and he was a drug addict and he
was so bad and he ignored me and he
didn't want to upset and he wanted to be
around me and he's also bad at eating
[ __ ] which then every time somebody
goes okay so you're a [ __ ] gold
diggers because I'm not a gold digger
I'm like so you've literally never given
one reason why you liked being with him
like every clip that we've played is why
he was terrible even we're not talking
about now when you broke up even when
you guys were dating we were playing
clips from 2019 remember 2017 when all
you were doing was talking [ __ ] about
him so like do you like anything about
him why were you with him so long other
than the fact that
and then she broke up with him because
she probably told him I'm just imagining
to take that Netflix show even though
she talked him out of it because she's
like that I know she is she's she's the
one that talks you into a bad decision
and then it's like I can't believe you
did that and then she probably goes why
don't you fight back
where are you turned on a Jamie Foxx
movie why did you do that she's one of
those [ __ ] that posted online I told
the guy to want to be with him he said
okay and then block me man he didn't
even fight or anything that's how these
women are now because women want you
women want to put you through a [ __ ]
won't put you through [ __ ] and khalilo's
the worst of the [ __ ] Bunch because I
believe at this point and it's my only
explanation she does this for sexual
gratification
she's a legit psychopath if you Dad are
diagnosed they would diagnose her as a
psychopath easily she's like Jeffrey
Dahmer except Jeffrey Dahmer had the
decency to only killed
[Laughter]
I'm kidding Jeffrey Dahmer was gay
if we make a clip yeah you could bleep
that one out I'm sorry I apologize peel
you know what I mean you know the life
hump yeah oh life home for sure yeah the
life hump right he's just gonna have to
take this whole segment and put it just
like a [ __ ] Sunny card over it the
boys talk about how Jeffrey Dahmer is
[ __ ] lgbtq history
all it is is like all right so here's
kalila talking about Bobby then 10
minutes of
and a black screen
[Music]
what if this like what if we get the
surprise ending what if he snaps and
kills her
oh God that'd be so based
I mean I get it but you really think
that vagmaster Bobby Lee is going to be
able to kill her bro I'm telling you
it's always the squirrely little guys
like that you can only push them so far
you bend them too much eventually they
break yeah
yeah but maybe he's bendy like the Asian
guy from Ocean's 11.
yo you could be and oceans [ __ ]
hiding in a hat box you know I see Bobby
Lee doing it uh he's just like standing
on a balcony berating him and he just
[ __ ] grabs her and jumps off
both of them
taking us both out oh [ __ ] man look we
come to the end of the show that was
[ __ ] great we're not gonna go any
better than that